[Music]
do you know the things that constitute
potential threats to crops harsh weather
insects pests and what else weeds that's
right with their home for plants that
grow alongside the crops why are weeds
considered to be a threat it's because
these plants to have roots which take up
the nutrients from the soil and they
compete for sunlight and water this
could seriously damage the crops leaving
them with little or no nutrients at all
so how do farmers get rid of these
plants
farmers usually remove all weeds in the
initial stage of soil preparation while
tilling the soil almost all weeds are
uprooted and there remains service
humours to the soil however if these
weeds grow after the crop assault they
need to be removed manually this can be
done with bare hands or with medicines
which kill these plants wait what do I
mean by medicines won't these medicines
damage the crop well these are known as
we decides and are designed to only kill
weeds these chemicals are diluted using
water and that's spread over the firms
farmers also use implements like a copy
or a CD drill to uproot weeds now tell
me can weeds be removed any time or
should we destroy them before a
particular time yes width should be
uprooted before they produce flowers and
seeds we decides to should be sprayed
before the flower but extreme caution
must be maintained while spraying these
chemicals can you guess why
well these chemicals can prove harmful
even to the farmers and that is why you
see farmers covering the nose and mouths
with a piece of cloth while spraying
these chemicals
now that you've studied about crop
protection against weeds let us study
the second last stage of crop production
this stage where the crop has matured
after a span of 3 to 4 months it's the
harvest time and what does it exactly
harvest the crops simply means to cut
the crop after it has matured do you
think it's as easy as it sounds of
course not
harvesting of crops if done manually is
done with a sickle if the machine is
used to harvest crops it is usually the
harvester crops are either pulled out or
cut close to the ground once the crop is
harvested it needs to be thrashed what
do I mean by thrashed the grains need to
be separated from the stalks threshing
is the next step after harvesting and is
carried out manually however even
machines called threshers are employed
for this nowadays in certain cases
farmers use a combination of harvester
and thresher a machine called combine
the machinery can carry out the process
of harvesting and threshing together
threshing is usually the beating of
stalks on a surface that separates the
grains from the stalks now the grains
have yet another covering before they
can be finally stored that is the chaff
chaff is then separated by a process
called winnowing in this process small
farmers manually separate the chaff from
grains with the help of the wind grains
are dropped down from a height and the
wind carries away the chaff while the
grains being heavier get collected into
a heap so with the three processes of
harvesting threshing and winnowing
grains are now ready for storage do you
think storage of grains involves a lot
of work we will soon find out in our
next video
[Music]
you